we always hear about ai being the most
promising technology that everyone is
using on a daily basis and things like
that but in practice when we get into
the beats and bites it seems like most
of it is based on you know very manual
very labor-intensive processes
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
seruna partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am so
excited for this episode with me isophil
chakon the ceo and co-founder of datagen
ophir is an entrepreneur with over a
decade of software experience combined
with computer vision and deep
algorithmic research he received his bsc
and embassy in engineering with honors
from the technion under the brakim elite
program with a research focus on robotic
simulations and dynamic systems ophelia
is the ceo and co-founder of datagen the
leading synthetic data company which
creates the next generation for data and
computer vision ai
opherochacon welcome to 20 minute
leaders i've been waiting so long to
talk to you about data gen and about
synthetic data and the world of
artificial intelligence which i love
so very much because of the infinite
possibilities it brings thank you for
being here with me thank you thank you
very much michael it's a pleasure to be
here and definitely i was waiting for
this call for quite some time so it's
pleasure to be here amazing i i have the
the the very unique privilege of of
being a very small part of the journey
of data gym so thank you for the
opportunity for that but beyond that
i the real opportunity that i'm getting
is getting exposed to some of the
amazing work that you're doing and
really an enablement for for
organizations that are
doing
deep ai to create better models and
better algorithms that at the end serve
humanity and and you know push our world
to new to new measures so i feel
were you always so passionate about ai
specifically you've done a lot of things
with ai before but you're an engineering
profession how did you get into this
specific field
right so it's quite an interesting story
i started my journey at the age of i
think six or seven
while my mother bought me the first html
book and uh you know it oh my god yeah
she used to say that it's basically the
the first investment she she made at me
since uh you know she was so super young
did she also make you sign a contract
for some equity in a safe exactly this
is where she bought the equity uh and
you know in me pretty much and uh
yeah since then i pretty fast found
myself on the intersection between tech
and entrepreneurship so you know started
building all these
uh small businesses while i was young
including you know building some
websites hosting some websites and
things like that obviously i did so many
mistakes back then but it was a
an amazing university for me
um
and then yeah later on i went to the
tech neon um to basically graduate both
bachelors and masters
in engineering and i think that
somewhere around my master's degree this
is where i really dove into ai and
computer vision uh while it was really
the beginning of this entire
field specifically in the context of
robotics dynamics and things like that
so it was super fascinating to
really see and learn what's uh what what
ai is really capable of doing back then
and
was it trivial for you that you're going
to be diving into this world not just as
a data scientist yourself but as a
company builder because at this point
we're the place where data gen is today
and soon i'd love for you to share a
little bit about about the traction that
you have and where you're headed you're
no longer just a data scientist you now
am a ceo you're an entrepreneur you're a
leader by profession
was that a trivial thing for you
yeah so i think that yeah i
kind of like found myself trying to you
know thinking about a lot of ideas and
trying to implement them and basically
i think was driven really by
trying to find uh you know someone that
will benefit from what i'm building from
a very young age
and i think that this is like i always
wanted to find
an interesting combination between
building things but being able to also
deliver them
um you know to uh and deliver value with
them and i think that once i went into
ai when it was super super
you know preliminary back then i found
that there are so many different
opportunities in this field
and it was very very premature back then
so i started you know working in the
industry making sure that i
grasped more and more of the different
moving parts
[Music]
and then when the time really came
i decided to really build something that
will be more substantial in the future
and this is where i co-founded
the company with uh with my partner gil
uh who is you know smart one of the
smartest guy guys i know he's coming
from also a very deep technical
background
from the technion
and he also brings a very interesting
experience in 3d computer vision and
computer graphics and this is where we
decided to really focus ourselves we
knew that this is where
you know both of us are
have the most kind of like knowledge and
understanding
and you know pretty much where you know
where we started if you know if we get
to the to really the entry point of data
gen it was kind of kind of a funny story
we were sitting in this uh cafe in in
tel aviv and you know browsing some
youtube videos
um and suddenly this video by zuckerberg
you know bumps up
quite a crazy video when he presents the
oculus device for the for the first time
on stage so i don't know if you know
this video it's quite a popular one he
you know stands on stage where
um he has an audience of thousands
people uh
look look like zombies with the with the
headset on their face
and you know when he starts the uh you
know the keynote and he puts the uh the
oculus on his face and then you know he
gets into a crazy new whole new virtual
virtual world
uh which was which was you know super
innovative and and you know game changer
technology back then
but on the other hand something was
quite weird uh for us in this in this
presentation and what was weird for us
is that
um he basically needed to hold remote
controllers in his hands
in order to kind of like interact uh
with the virtual wall and we come from
the computer vision space and we
understand that this you know camera
this device this really sorry this
device has cameras on the you know
external side that looking outwards and
basically they are expected to
understand the world around the device
and specifically the hands and be able
to integrate them into the the virtual
space in a simple way but it wasn't the
case and he really needed to hold these
remote controls in order to uh get this
interaction to work uh so at this point
we understood that okay there is you
know a gap here that facebook suffers
from and given that facebook is one of
the let's say you know more mature
groups in computer vision in the world
both back then and obviously now
uh we you know we made an assumption
that probably this gap is basically
shared amongst a lot of customers and
this is where we really you know kicked
off the journey
i love it take me through a little bit
of a higher level understanding of of
you know where the ai world you know was
and is today that that is sort of
enabling you as that agenda coming in
and especially around this idea of
synthetic data and and as more and more
companies are are you know are building
these algorithms for their own for their
own uses and for to advance the world
where are we at because you know the
progression of ai is is an incredible
life story but you know specifically in
the world of synthetic data how do we
get to here
right
so when we started datagen i think that
the world of ai really suffered from
lack of standardization meaning it's
almost like when the internet started
and then everyone created his own you
know browser and formats and and
protocols and things like that so this
is where we found the world of ai when
we started and you know it was
on one hand it's like you have complete
mess in the world but on the other hand
it's like a huge opportunity to create
so many interesting companies around
these things
and over the past few years you really
saw that there were
quite a lot of fields that progressed
very very fast specifically if we
uh kind of like
try to to
dissemble the world of ai into building
blocks you can distinguish between three
main building blocks right so the first
one would be compute
second one would be algo ethereums or
models or deep learning networks and
things like that and then the third one
will be
data while the two first ones both the
compute and the algorithms we can see
that over the past few
years they really progressed quite
significantly and there were you know
tremendous improvements and advancement
in these fields they both
get more and more mature exponentially
year over year
and we decided no not to focus on on
these just because there are very good
companies you know tackling these both
areas
but but when we look at on the you know
more in the data part of things this is
where i think
uh the most uh opportunity is because
this is where uh you know the the the uh
kind of like the industry as as a whole
really suffers from a lot of again lack
of standardization and and you know
traditional processes that haven't been
optimized over
over the past years
and
if we're looking at the opportunities
that synthetic data can provide to the
world and to these organizations rather
than you know they're just the way that
they've been accumulating data until now
for their algorithms what opportunities
do you see in the grand vision of things
as we're positioning for it and then i'd
love to understand a little bit more
about the journey of datagen as a
company
right um so when we look at how
how teams are now
um you know acquiring data
in order to train and test their ai
algorithms
it's i have to say quite a ridiculous
process meaning
they are let's say you know a team in
for example a company like walmart right
they want
basically to track
the activity of
you know shoppers walking around the
store grabbing some things off of
shelves maybe for chess like self
checkout purposes and things like that
for you know in order to train a an ai
algo with them to to do that what they
would need to do is to go and basically
collect hundreds of millions of images
from the real world of all sorts of
different shoppers walking around in
different stores in different lighting
conditions and grabbing different
products from shelves and maybe you know
putting things in their shopping cart
and then getting it out on getting it
back on the shelf and all these type of
edge cases
in order for basically for the ai system
to be able to detect them after once
it's trained so this is a complete
manual process right they go and they
literally capture images from the world
using cameras
that would obviously be
quite quite a mess in order to collect
all this data that to cover all the
different use cases that you can find
that you would imagine this ai would
would work well on and then they need to
kind of like annotate all these images
by hand one by one to basically
highlight where the shopper is and where
the item is and where the shopping cart
is and things like that so all these
processes nowadays you know we always
hear about ai being the most promising
technology that everyone is using on a
daily basis and things like that but in
practice when we get into the bits and
bytes
it seems like most of it is based on you
know very manual very labor-intensive
processes in order to acquire all this
data from the real world and label it
and clean it and all these type of types
of things and eventually these ai
systems suffer from a lot of you know
for example privacy things and biases as
we hear on the news every day
just because they weren't trained on the
right data to achieve the right task and
i think this is where synthetic data
really comes in so
the way or the concepts of synthetic
data is the ability to rather than go
and really
manually acquire all these data from the
real world
completely again with humans that are
they don't really have control over what
they are doing and
we don't really know what data we infuse
into our system
we take a completely new approach and
what we do in datagen is we built a 3d
simulation of the real world that will
look you know behave feel and interact
exactly like the real world
for example we have 3d virtual people
that would go and enter a store
a virtual store and would take virtual
items off of shelves and everything is
completely simulated using computer
graphics and computer vision
but we don't just create you know one
shopper in one store right because we
have full control over this simulation
software we're able to go and basically
have hundreds of thousands of shoppers
in millions of stores that are
interacting with the stores in you know
hundreds of millions of different ways
and with all this control and with all
these variants we're actually able then
to
capture virtually all these images from
the simulation software like they were
taken from the real world and in this
way we pretty much give the
engineering teams of the future
to go and have the all the control they
need they need on their data so from a
place where let's say they acquired
their data and it took them six months
to you know collect one data set they
turn into something that would basically
be
um you know a few hours to generate one
data set
they can train their model see how it
performs and then generate the next data
at the same day
and this new paradigm this new like this
shifting in mindset would really make
them
get to market and get their ai systems
to perform better in production
way way way faster
so we're talking you know about about
scale of data about the diversification
of data sets about the the timeliness of
getting the data and in general i mean
these things are translated to massive
amounts of both money for the
organizations both in terms of the time
of the engineers and the operational
side and time to market of that they
might be losing but also just the the
that you're cutting short in a huge
chunk of the process of what is going to
be you know a cornerstone of of their
business at the end i mean this is where
businesses are headed and this also
treats itself like another
another element that we've been hearing
a lot about in the last few years which
is about the biases that data sets have
and your ability to own
the biases that you're putting into your
data sets and obviously here you know
this and it sounds inherently that i
come that a product like datagen allows
you to monitor that much more closely
and if you do realize you you might have
a bias because of the way you configure
the data you want you're able to adjust
that because you're able to create new
synthetic data right
yes i think one of the interesting
trends that we see
you know in the in the i think in the
entire let's say industry in general is
that
engineers really have a lot of power
in today's world right and they are
turning to be the main buyers and users
of
all the different you know software
products that we see out there and a lot
of startups are turning to basically be
you know developer first tools and i
think what datagen is doing besides this
kind of like revolution around the way
we want to shift the world from being
very manual
to be very very automated we also give
this full control over the data that you
need to the you know into the engineers
hands and by that we really give them
everything they need and they can really
kind of like control as
like everything they need
in order to progress with their
algorithms uh you know way way faster
and what you said about biases is
actually quite interesting also because
nowadays when you feed you know with
data that you collected from the real
world into your ai system it's very hard
to know uh how your system will perform
on
on different uh you know things for
example male versus female or even you
know bias is not just you know we always
think of biases like you know gender
bias or ethnicity bias but in practice
when we think about bias in the most
broader sense
bias is basically every ratio between
two parameters in your system for
example how your system performs on dark
scenes versus light scenes on red tables
versus blue tables all these type of
things can be you know your your network
can be biased towards you know
tables that are white instead of brown
and things like that so the idea with
synthetic data which is quite
interesting is that because you know
exactly what you generate from your
simulation software
you can basically
unbias your network if you found any
failures or edge cases that your network
is not performing well on and on the
other hand if you want to even test your
network and make sure it performs
you know the same and what maintains the
level of for performance over time what
you can do is you can treat your
synthetic data as testing data sets that
you can run through your network every
week for example exactly like we do with
code when we run unit tests for our code
every time we push code to production
um and then we can make sure that the
system performs very well on previously
trained you know data sets and things
like that and that we maintain the same
level of performance over time i feel i
i love it and i think i'm i'm inspired
by by the the grand understanding that
what you're sharing here and and not
talking about is a specific pinpoint or
suspect specific problem that you might
be solving but looking at the industry
as a whole and understanding that
there's something greater here that we
need to address and this is the way that
engineers
hundreds of thousands millions of
engineers around the world are facing
and at the end this this is the core of
technology today and this is the the
enablement of what's going to happen and
how our next models are going to be
built and not just allowing the
companies to do it better but to do it
more safely and to monitor it much
better and and personally i'm looking at
datagen and while i'm excited for the
companies that may be using it because
it'll make their lives better it also
makes the consumers lives better because
the models are built as intended and and
i personally believe that a lot of the
mistakes that algor that models are
doing today are unintended consequences
i don't believe that engineers come and
they want to portray a bias to their
algorithm but they just didn't have the
right data or maybe they cut corners
because it took them six months to
accumulate it and so i think what you're
doing here is much bigger than than just
you know giving them a much better way
to acquire the data well fear before we
end i i'm really curious as a
technologist and
a scientist yourself now you're a leader
and now you're running a company that is
growing very quickly and doing very well
what have you discovered about this art
of running a company that maybe you
didn't know before you started or that
wasn't very trivial to you as a young
entrepreneur before
right
so i think that in practice
uh one of the most interesting things
that i learned along the way
is that
people is everything right like peop
like when you run a company you really
need to invest your resources uh in the
right place
um and people tend to think that the
companies i don't know the product that
you're building the code base that
you're developing
um you know the sales machines that you
are creating and things like that
but in practice uh company companies
don't really exist without the people
and the knowledge the experience and the
real iep
uh the intellectual property of the
company would be really you know 99 of
it would be the people that you bring
how you treat them how you train them
um and you know how you you grow them
into to be
real leaders and professionals
and we really believe in it like from
the very beginning of the company we
brought in
not only professionals but people that
are really fun to work with have high
emotional intelligence that they
communic they can communicate well
people that you know they can both give
and receive feedback in a very direct
and honest way
uh and we built a work environment that
uh you know just you know it's it's
amazing to join and you know i'm still
having opening talks with every new team
member that we have although we're
already nose to 90 people so it's quite
insane wow
90 people
and and and it's always you know a
pleasure to just meet people that i
haven't even interviewed which is also
for me quite crazy to to digest that i'm
not i'm no longer interviewing everyone
uh but you know meeting them for the
first time and hearing about their
onboarding experience after let's say
two weeks uh you know into the company
it's it's so amazing to hear our how
other team members treating them and how
professional and you know thorough the
the onboarding process was
not on the professional side again
mostly on really the person on the side
people are really trying to help them
and support them and really want them to
to succeed and i think that for me that
would be you know a real success being
able to hear from the 90th employee that
that they feel exactly the same like the
fifth employee
that would be for me you know a big
success because it means that we really
were able to take the dna of both both
you know my co-founder gil and i
and implanted so so deep in the in the
culture of the company uh and make sure
that other people they pretty much live
and breathe the the values that we that
we started with like you know three
years ago
i love it and uh
just sounds like an amazing journey oh
phil thank you very much for for
20 minutes with me thank you for the
great work that you're doing for the
industry as a whole and beyond the
beyond datagen success the way i said
that agent success is the industry's
success because of the way that that
you're building out the the the product
and the way that you're then going to
shape the the type of work that other
companies are doing so thank you very
much for everything and best of luck
with datagen and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much it was a
pleasure
[Music]
you